you got you guys went to alaska it's
like an energy project right you know so
i sort of like just
let me let me like in alaska yeah i want
to preface real quick uh just to prime
this
we went from being energy independent to
dependent in the blink of an eye in the
blink of an eye and there's there's a
lot that contributes to it but then you
get you know joe biden's releasing the
sanctions on nordstrom 2.
you get uh there's there's other
pipelines they're trying to do from
central asia and the middle east up into
into europe
they you know the biden administration
shuts down keystone
they ban uh fracking on federal lands
then the press has the gall to come out
and say biden is not causing high gas
prices i just want to make sure there's
a few things that are clear before we
get into this
when you shut down the keystone pipeline
and ban some fracking speculators say
wow supply is going to be strained it's
a good time to buy because in a few
years it's going to be worth way more
that instantly drives up prices that
hits you when you buy a gallon of gas so
uh so you weren't necessarily doing an
energy project or or you know you were
yeah i mean yes it would yes or no it
was that but also more than just that
and so when we look at these discussions
like afghanistan the middle east rare
earth minerals these elements that china
is gobbling up around the world one belt
one road uh the petro dollar so you know
which obviously bitcoin is a huge hedge
against right all of these various
discussions that go on
then we never seem to turn around and
actually have the discussion of well why
does all of that stuff matter so much
why are we so beholden to all of these
various things is this really the best
way to run our country what if you know
and i say this on twitter and i've been
saying it more since i got back from
alaska is
what you know i don't want to go
straight full fortress america right you
know i want to have commerce obviously
we want to have trade but at the same
time is
are we running our country in a way
that's most beneficial for the american
people who live here now today and are
we developing our own resources for the
benefit of our people versus putting
ourselves at the mercy of these cartels
like opec which is a cartel literally
the actual mexican cartels etc etc and
all of these other various things
because we've gotten ourselves head over
heels for these international agreements
rather than just looking internally
seeing what we have here and helping the
people of this country what if we spent
two trillion dollars and deployed our
military to alaska to nation build in
alaska
the resources the potential energy i
know what if we did that would be you
would have you would at least have a
10-fold return on your investment you
have a city yeah yeah you have a city of
americans we've been mining copper as a
human race for about 5 000 years this
was a great statistic that we learned
about this potential copper mine we've
been mining copper for about five
thousand
copper is the big thing they're talking
about
in afghanistan yeah i've got tons of
copper lithium right copper and lithium
right the amount of copper we have mined
over the past 5 000 years
we will need twice that
if we are going to all drive electric
vehicles by the year 2030. wow assuming
that we use copper wiring
graphene part of graphene is that
and and if it works as a technology
fascinating but right now we use copper
yeah right so industries we need copper
you're your hybrid vehicle your your
prius and it's going to come from
somewhere has about 80 pounds of copper
and well now we have a mandate and
that's just the prius right the bigger
ones and the buses have up to 300 pounds
of copper that's for the electric motor
that's all for that's all part of the
battery that's the battery yeah the
chords
the coil the the coil phone yeah excuse
me um
we all we're going to need a lot of
copper where are we going to get the
copper from that's just a a legit
question right we're going to need an
awful lot of lithium we're going to need
cobalt cadmium nickel gold graphite
china understands all of this by the way
very well one state that has all of
these things wow but it's our playground
and and rich white
and i won't even say liberals because
it's a lot of conservatives who look at
alaska as like oh it's so pretty we
shouldn't do anything there and the
reason why we wanted to do this trip is
because when you meet alaskans who say i
would really like a job because there's
nothing going on here but if we open up
this mine i could maybe do something
right and we'll do the mine responsibly
because we are so so wait let me tell
the story about how you actually get us
to the mic right this is this is like
the you know we wake up and we're in
anchorage and he said jack we're gonna
go see the you know and it's not a mine
now it's it's it's the deposit because
not you know wow it has been it's been
tested but right now there are no you
know there's no holes nothing being dug
nothing no there's there isn't even a
shovel in the ground there right been
waiting 17 years and so see we're going
to check it out it's all right here
check it out or whatever daniel whatever
you want to do right so i got my coffee
and then we and then we drive out to
uh there's so uh alaska is big right you
know and and that i don't mean that as
an understatement alaska is massive the
size of texas
i think it's i think it's more like
three and a half text sizes it's it's
massive
absolutely mexican this is taxi
anyone in the lower 38 who's never been
there cannot appreciate the scale
of alaska
we just have nothing else like it on the
map it gets squished right the northern
hemisphere let me i pulled up an overlay
image yeah and it stretches from central
michigan to central minnesota the
aleutians go
if you're in
alaska
you uh in the easternmost point you are
in florida and the westernmost point
you're in sacramento right whoa yes yeah
the main landmass i think it would it
would be fair to say florida to new
mexico
yeah wow so so we get in an airplane
from anchorage we fly about about an
hour
right and then we fly about an hour so
we're going across uh two bays to get to
this this tiny little
remote middle of nowhere village village
that's just sitting there it's a native
village
and then and he says all right we're
gonna hang out here for a little bit and
then we're gonna get a helicopter i said
what do you mean we're not like we're
not here already right and we'll talk
about the village in a minute but they
said no no we're gonna get a helicopter
okay fine so we get on the helicopter
and then the helicopter is what another
40 minutes or so so now you're in the
helicopter you're going 40 minutes and
you're just out and there's no roads
right so aviation is actually huge in
alaska because it's so big um i think
they have like one of the highest per
capita of private aviation and pilots
licenses and everything you have to
because you have to you just if you want
to get
from point a to point b the roads are
you know they're not great or they're
not they don't exist in many cases and
so you've got so we're in the helicopter
and a new zealand pilot actually kiwi
and um told to look out for bears you
told look out for babies look out for
bears because they attack you know i was
petrified we get out of there number one
totally i've done this so many times i'm
i'm afraid of bears it took us four no
no no we weren't armed but we did a
helicopter though um so we get all the
way out there
and we're flying and it's and i'm look
i'm waiting for like these we all you
you see all those like those
ever it feels like every other reality
show is like set in alaska right so i'm
looking for the rivers and the streams
and we flew over some like at one point
but then for most of it it's just it's
just barren yep it's just barren
desolate uh because it's tundra you know
a lot of this is just tundra so it's
it's frosted over rocks a little bit of
grass no trees
and i'm like
i'm like all right daniel you made me
wake up at six in the morning to get all
the way out here and it's for this
one second i gotta see this
it's the same thing as what i was
imagining
right and i'm like
what is this
and daniel looks at me and he says jack
underneath your feet right now
is over a trillion dollars
in copper
and in six months that'll be 1.3
trillion yeah
exactly exactly and and i'm like and i'm
looking at them like
did we bring shovels
let's get the comfort daniel
what are you doing you know and and he's
like we're not allowed like
who says
washington mm-hmm
and then and
that's what kind of word the story and
i'll eat it but that's kind of where
it blows your mind that you're just out
in and by the way that's only one valley
right you could go to the next and the
next one over and there could be that's
all we know about right i understand uh
you know environmentalism for sure sure
but we're not talking about taking a a
this is not a national park of yeah
fifth of alaska and blowing it up we're
talking about probably what is a square
mile or or what is even in that is it
even that oh it's yeah it's probably
probably square mile that's probably
another square mile in alaska which is
and could i i'm just i'm sorry i would
it was not it is not literally it is not
a postage stamp on a football field what
if we just took that 2 trillion over 20
years instead of afghanistan and said
hey i got an idea let's nation build in
our nation and uh i mean not even alaska
we got wyoming and montana how about
that the reason why we're doing it is
not environmental reasons that's that's
the facade is environmental reasons
environmental concerns the reason why
which is why i started this organization
and got into the business because the
people who own copper rights in other
countries fund groups like the sierra
club and the national resource defense
council and and earth first and
environmental defense fund they fund
these groups to say we have to protect
the earth because they own the mineral
rights in chile
afghanistan the taliban is going to now
sell them all to china right on they own
this this is the big trees this is the
big thing with the afghan that is the
taliban
and china so china going in all those
photos you're seeing around of of china
meeting with the taliban leaders right
this is all about the copper and the
lithium deposits in afghanistan and i'm
sorry the 17 year old like kids like
with the tambourines and the hacky sac
who are saying we got to protect the
earth you are a puppet so you've never
been there you are a puppet of a huge
conglomerate that does not want 1.3
trillion dollars worth of copper on the
market because it will affect
commodities prices and so they want to
keep it in places that have no osha have
no imagine a copper miner which by the
way this is going online in indonesia i
would encourage you to look up copper
mine chile waste copper chile waste
giant strip mines massive pools of like
this colored liquid that's apparently
super toxic i mean you don't think that
and chile is there making sure that so
you're saying there's no like there's
less
regulations that's the reason why we
like to mine in other countries because
you and you can use eight-year-old girls
right have have the in let's talk about
where that cobalt's going and the congo
right the largest cobalt producer the
mines are owned by china but they're in
the congo 30 000 children slaves work
there right now
i'm guilty i have cobalt in my iphone as
we talk so you admit it absolutely it
turned out you know but we just we just
pretend we it's not happening now we
could mine cobalt in other countries but
it would be expensive so let's just use
the slave children in the congo because
no one cares about the slave children in
the congo so when we want to open up a
lithium mine in alaska or a cobalt mine
or a gold mine or a copper mine
rather than hurt prices we hire a bunch
of hippie kids to say protect the earth
and we start a group called moms against
asthma and we fund all of these
different people and they go and they
bang and they cry and they talk about
raping the earth and it is all just one
but it is all there's another piece
there's another piece to this slide so
it's after we get back from there and
i'm
i'm
just and you have that idea right and
plus if you actually look at the history
of alaska um so alaska was
a territory for a very very very long
time since like post civil almost 100
years like post civil war on out and
people didn't want to make it a state
originally because they were concerned
that it wouldn't be self-sustaining
because they they're thinking hey this
whole area is just a wasteland why
should we give them statehood we're
going to have to completely carry them
they're going to pay their way on the
way this is before but then oil is
discovered up there and so in the 1950s
it's 59
um
well they get the the statehood yep so
they get state and they say wait a
minute okay now you have the ability to
sustain yourselves there is a reason we
are going to give you statehood because
then that will give us access to the
resources down here that we need in the
lower 48 so the whole idea of alaska was
that you will be given statehood and
that we will then be able to develop
these resources for the betterment of
the american people throughout the
country right
these will be our goods this will be
america we'll put actual americans to
work we don't have to worry about this
all these trade issues and you know the
kids in the congo etc we can do it all
right here uh and we can set it to our
standards and do it just the way we want
then
so afterwards i'm sitting there thinking
and it's it's it is you kind of get that
like gold bug a little bit when you're
sitting there i still have it a little
bit where i'm like there's a trillion
dollars like there's a trillion dollars
in copper i just want to go can i just
get like a nugget like a little bit you
know
you know
my wife she could use some copper
jewelry maybe right you know and um
she didn't come with us to the you know
the wasteland and um but then he took us
to the village
and i got to tell you that
of everything that we did and we went
also went up to prudo we did some of the
touristy stuff while we were up in
alaska but
this this village that we went to the
native village
i i can't get some of the images out of
my head
and i can't get some of the stuff that
so we met with the leaders of the
village and i can't get some of the
stuff that they told me
out of my head the amount of poverty
that they live under
60 unemployment in these towns right
they
and and the towns are all and they're
dying because there there's no job it's
so remote so people understand it's so
remote they have one
little building where they have that you
know that's the school they don't have
there's and you want to talk about
infrastructure right you know uh correct
me for one but there's no there wasn't
even a doctor there no like a doctor
like not i'm not saying that wasn't a
doctor's office there wasn't even a
doctor a couple people had cell phones
but there's no internet yeah there was
like a physician's assistant
i think was the closest they came and
then if you wanted to see a doctor you'd
be better be able to afford a plane
ticket right um there's no bridge across
the main lake to get you anywhere yeah
and the flight to anchorage was about
500 a person so if you need to yeah go
to get your braces
well you gotta on top of that you need
to pay the 500 flight to attack how long
of a flight does it take about an hour
and it reminded me of um
just some of the some places i've seen
in south like southeast asia um
places that have been to it
but this is america this is the united
states of america these are american
citizens the government is kind of like
oh i asked you this before the show you
guys that they forgive like they
basically are ignoring these people
because they're the descendants of
natives
i don't think that's why but that is
also what that's how also what's
happening because they'll
now what's what's different though is
and daniel you know this better than me
the
they don't have
the same type of i should i guess i
could say agreements that were made
between the us government and the
natives that you would see that you're
more that you're more used to seeing in
not that natives are treated well
throughout you know u.s history but i'm
just saying that it's a different
situation that you would see like
reservations etc throughout uh the west
in the u.s in the lower 48th the
contiguous us in alaska they don't have
that this is because alaska was formed
as a state after all these reservations
yeah
right so what's the difference like how
are they are they abused in like some
sort of specific way i mean obviously
it's all economics and
you know
god help you if you need police and if
there's some emergency that goes on
there's no cops
i think if you are an alaskan native and
you are on your
uh ancestral land
no you there's not gonna be amazon
fulfillment center right no one's gonna
move a factory there so what do you do
if you want to stay on your land what
what opportunities do you have well
natural resources seem to be the most
obvious but we've banned timber right
the governor told us we had dinner with
the governor he said rhode island has a
bigger timber industry than alaska does
wow right because because why because
alaska right alaska the largest state
and the smallest state
is it because temperature it's because
it's it's our little private park so
here's a lot of rules here's a line
here's a line that somebody said and uh
that we met up there and they were like
a lot of there's a lot of transplants to
alaska um you know from the low 40
people go up there and i i can't wait to
get back honestly this i go to look i
travel a lot for um from my work i go to
i've been to i think 43 44 states plus
guam and uh i loved alaska i absolutely
loved it i can't wait to go back
i get it i totally get it just you know
there for a week and i get it but
so we met somebody who had previously
been a dc staffer
and one thing she was saying was
what a lot of people think of alaska is
this is this
giant beautiful national park
that i might like to visit someday and
so i'm going to oppose every single
effort to do anything that might disrupt
my potential dream
of being there someday because i have
nothing no idea what i'm talking about
but every time i've watched a you know a
documentary or a reality tv show they
always show these and there are some
beautiful um parts of alaska that i do
agree should be preserved right um and
we're not talking about those areas
we're that we're not talking about those
national parks we're talking about these
wastelands deserts and and essentially
deserts right right it's tundra is it is
a type of desert um arctic deserts that
have resources that are incredibly
valuable to our people number one to our
development to our progress and add
additional benefit we don't have to deal
with china we don't have to deal with
the taliban we don't have to care about
any of this stuff anymore because it's
right there and we can do it with
environmental stewardship we can do it
with respect for
the earth and and native communities and
we get the taxes and we get the jobs i
mean the fact that the president was on
the one hand closing down anwar leases
and then saying we want opec to produce
more oil you say well wait a second why
if you so you're you're acknowledging
that global climate change is a myth
because if opec is producing more oil
then that's global climate change so so
right off the bat your arguments about
climate change you've dismissed them by
this statement but if opec can produce
the oil why can't america produce the
oil why can't we get the jobs why can't
we give you tax revenue
beyond that real quick i mean there
there are many
we have hyper centralized in many cities
in the united states why aren't we
investing in some of these dying towns
before you we get off or new places like
alaska you got to talk about the general
store
oh and just the prices of you know
just tell a story yeah i mean just uh
we we go to this little store
um which is i'm going to the store the
store that's the store in town i
remember everything so what time was
this
the little town is called illyanna
alaska how do you spell this ili
uh it was out there
and it's next to the beautiful name
isn't it yeah yeah it's one of the
largest lakes in america actually is
lake ileana the lake
it's one of the largest freshwater lakes
um
[Music]
in in america i'm like where's where's
the disney movie right where's where's
you know uh you know the kingdom of
iliad treasures
trading co
that's the store is that the store that
was probably the name of the store the
store yeah so i did take some photos a
little bit i should be able to in
advance so i could show them to you so
this this um box you got like
everything there has to be brought in
but he has to show you the pictures
because he would not believe him this
box of apple jack box boxes apple jacks
10.58 cents 10.58 cents box family size
frosted mini wheats oh
10 bucks 22.50 cheese
half gallon of milk
16 bucks
13.49
one of the women talk about food
shortages this is where one of the women
said that's food shortage soda is
cheaper than milk and she said and when
you are seeing american moms put sprite
in a baby's bottle because they can't
afford milk we have a problem as a
country
and then but we're saying but you can't
open a pebble mine because it's bad for
the environment but the local native
women who are literally putting sprite
in their kids bottles because they can't
afford milk that's not my problem thanks
for checking out this clip from the tim
cast irl podcast if you want to see the
full show come back to this channel
youtube.com tim cast irl monday through
friday at 8pm where you can leave
comments and super chat and we actually
will read your comments on the show
don't forget to like share subscribe and
if you want exclusive members only
content segments you can't get anywhere
else go to timcast.com become a member
and we even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time